if you don't play in the gc today
how different
manometer
so french jump on the board on
usual variation but not not
bad for black
so that's quite interesting on the other hand
yes i would have thought i can just take
the five or not
by the way means unexpected from the
united arab emirates
that you want to take out the red runners that
we want to keep at exhibitions
so
push in 3 he maybe had
to me 8
volts at least
not just a little cramped
here for the
walldorfer to be able to do the 1 with it
the towers  came
so that good ideas would like to play
jumper 64
who overlooked 10x looks a
bit strange because
I thought I think yes
from afar
so against such jumpers has three and
similar actions
it looks very good now
so I give the team
but can also play him
first,
yes, I trust him again down there, I
dac  hte that can't be
given for free where he was also professional that
gives two strict points